an investigation is underway after a
top-secret US spy satellite apparently
failed to achieve orbit and disappeared
this photo taken over Africa is believed
to show a portion of the rocket carrying
the Zuma satellite falling back to earth
the classified satellite was launched to
aboard a SpaceX rocket on Sunday the
defense company Northrop Grumman built
the satellite it reportedly cost
billions of dollars David Martin is at
the Pentagon with what we are learning
about this space mystery David good
morning good morning the exact price of
the top-secret Zuma satellite is not
known but it is certain that US
intelligence suffered a great loss for
intelligence that needed and the US
taxpayer lost money on a satellite it
had bought three two one ignition
the spy satellite made by Northrop
Grumman was mounted in the nose of a
SpaceX Falcon 9 rocket we have had
successful liftoff of Falcon 9 carrying
Zuma a Sunday night launch appeared to
go flawlessly and we've just passed max
Cuse SpaceX said after a review of all
data Falcon 9 did everything correctly
Rockets first stage returned to earth so
it could be used again while the second
stage carried the satellite into
low-earth orbit bill Harwood is a space
consultant for CBS news in this case we
haven't heard a word from any agency
claiming responsibility for the
satellite they're giving us even a hint
about what might have gone wrong but the
Northrop Grumman satellite apparently
failed to separate from the second stage
the company would not comment saying it
was a classified mission if it didn't
separate from the second stage it would
crash back to earth along with it an
airline pilot took this picture of what
is believed to be the second stage
descending over Africa something
re-entered but we don't know whether the
payload was part of that reentry
Jonathan McDowell is an astronomer at
the harvard-smithsonian Center for
Astrophysics he believes the satellite
suffered the same fate as this cargo
ship captured in 2008 breaking up in
Earth's atmosphere and so this super
expensive secret payload went down in
flames over Africa and that's what we
think probably happened so it's pretty
tragedy for the people who worked on it
an investigation will now have to
determine exactly what happened and
which company SpaceX or Northrop Grumman
is responsible Laura all right David
thank you so much